yeah Gmail's one now that's the most
space for attachments
anyway iq feel free to hit me up if you
remember that number I noticed you ain't
write that down damn damn damn that girl
was fly right shy but did you see that
Liam Neeson's movie with them wolves
nope the one with the big-ass wolves and
Liam Neeson's is my Liam Neeson's
straight jacked up to me and don't even
get me started on that warm when they
took his daughter straight tooken
starring Liam Neeson's Lisa's on the
phone like I have a certain set of
skills don't even try and be rushing
around Liam Neeson in the second when
the brushes come after him anyway took
in two starring the incomparable Liam
Neeson
mmm that's what what about Darkman no no
huh what about Liam useless is some dark
man no what about dark Liam Neeson's
these face change now that's just Liam
Neeson's acting right to me straight up
I kid you not
academy-award caliber and classic
Neeson's Oh seriously I mean like
Neeson's already need to have a statue
you need to say cannot take out of touch
he ain't got a statue he ain't got a
statue nope nope nope
the Oscar goes to Liam Neeson's Darkman
face was changing how hard is day hard
up it's not hard to all the stupid most
ops battleship
this is straight killed a robot boat
Liam Neeson's is my shiznit
oh but you know who I like as much as
Neeson's through as much as Neeson's Oh
Bruce Willy what if they made a movie
with Liam Neeson
hey I'm go swimming Lisa's Willy Glee in
the water man harder
[Applause]
- aye yo may I ask you a question yeah
what why everybody messing with the
Batman see exactly what I've been asking
myself why would you do that why would
you try and how are you supposed to
block a Batarang from going in your butt
with a carefully crafted query
I'll tell you one thing no way you gonna
meows with the Batman
right now wait up Ra's al Ghul played by
the incomparable even when we are
talking about the Batman's
[Applause]
i dude I gotta tell you something last
night on Showtime's I saw some lethal
weapon 2
lethal weapon 2 starring the racist-ass
Melly Gibson's oh I know but I gotta
tell you right up front and truthfully
racist-ass Melly Gibson's is still think
about a man think about it remember
where he jacked up on their mutants and
the road warrior same yeah remember what
he had taken out a hatchet and chopped
up all them England's remember in the
racist-ass Melly Gibson's is still much
this was Blue Man Group in Bravehearts
or what about conspiracy theories don't
want ok what the about conspiracy
theories though what about conspiracy
theories be directed to yo racist-ass
Melly Gibson's be telling the story of a
bunch of crazy-ass old-fashioned Mexican
women in the jungle getting chased by
and what about that passions after
Christ Russians of the Christ though
racist-ass Melly Gibson's made that
movie about Jesus in a kind of
racist-ass way that was a module and you
know what I just realized dog what's
that you know all the mice but what
would be the Fraser says Melly Gibson's
co-starred in a movie with Jesus are you
talking about the Savior Hall the king
of all kings the Alpha and the Omega and
Jesus
[Music]
into miss Yahtzee yo aunt is about time
Shakespeare doth Scriven to play that
place is a brother amongst the
firmaments
Oh who's your favorite character might
as well that comely white maiden and
it's not anyone speaketh methinks things
are looking up for people of the darker
hue Oh Martin what's that I could borrow
a couple of ducats to purchase it's a
capon from yonder concession more please
you know I got a concealed Cornish game
hen up in my doublet
Oh y'all heard the ursher Shakespeare
was about to kill everybody up in this
bitch
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean that trifling ass Iago I knew he
was up to something to kill Tim in the
first act do himself in with a dagger
how does that help me tell you something
if a brother killed himself every time
he broke up with a white bitch this
world will be bereft of dollar you'll be
talking to a skull right okay mhm
where Shakespeare's that oh right they
were not the way okay
for the 8.8 make way make way
be gone CIRA a black man got it going on
and you shuffle off his mortal coil I
said to D that's the tragedy oh is that
not the Troubadour Kanye of the way oh
not wait
truth be told my Lords tis not I who
penned this dreadful play twas
Christopher Marlowe already tried to use
that line of argument when the Jews
wanted to kick your ass after the
Merchant of that we doth not purchase it
Slick Willy we does not purchase it
become my good Lords will not be long
before another black hero grace at the
stage and now if you let me not so fast
you alright that hero no verily that
mother
[Music]
so if I no no no no they hate
you know who they never be hating on
who's that dog Sandra Bullock sandra
bullocksies is my girl be hey go go
right here straight up their center
bullet is your girl right just right now
do you know who should do a movie
together
who is that got bullocksies and
hathaways you talk about some and some
but no i'm talking about some
bullocksies and some hathaways explain
what i'm talking about down i'm talking
about some hathaways and some
bullocksies good I thought something was
going me 2004 second city we will
transform in some way shape or form okay
[Applause]
it up could you get up to this weekend
odo ah you know me man
kind of all up in their bread box oh
yeah yeah yeah you know who's good know
who that got Robert Downey's juniors
Robert Downey's juniors door door which
one Tony Stark's daughter starts damn it
Tony Stark's Iron Man's oh I'm gonna be
building this own so nobody was proper
Patsy oh yeah yo mama's got a glowing
heart in that one one one one you've
give that statue for that alone right
there but you know another thing about
all these go to it sherlocky holmes
sherlocky holmesies
what Sherlock's his homies we're not pit
and all of a sudden his mind I'll go do
this and it statistically gots to do
this okay and the McCain and then he was
remembered one scene where he woke up in
his neighbor's daughter's bed on drugs
no that was already squared in real life
told her it was it was that was real she
was doing in that one no that was very
realistic
ya know was good vally Kilmer's oh we're
talking about vally Kilmer's right now
you know vally Kilmer's in tombstones
hot what holidays okay we've got the
Kilmer's in willows dough Oh what about
vally Kilmer's in that willows know he
was mad Marty Kinsey there was in that
medieval toboggan
talk about Kilmer's in the Saints my man
my man was like and then he was like and
it I see that one just the cover look at
jealousy know what I'm realizing right
now for the first time is like if there
was a graph of Rd square and vally
Kilmer's careers yeah yeah RT square
would start down here right vally
Kilmer's would be starting right up here
and RD square would get this trajectory
going in there vally Kilmer's beyond
this trajectory right here like this
place they're just making a movie
sickening things just get a little crazy
just little drugs just a little busy
make it still making movies and then
they meet at this point in the same
movie which is why the best movie of all
time is kiss kiss
[Music]
[Applause]
yo what's up Game of Thrones told y'all
you all caught up y'all totally
binge-watched that whole thing last
night so it's cold blooded up in
Westeros it starts you ain't see now
I'll comment you know I mean my man was
just dead right down there
I worry they gonna kill my point man
start and then plop I was like
cold-blooded up in there and then I was
like but that's okay because I still got
my big Dave Navarro thing saving the
farmers that do picked up some molten
gold I mean he be like Hercules I'm like
you can't kill Drago for the paper and
in fact this scratching is so he got
straight killed which is y'all but you
know what my favorite character is it
Khaleesi sleaze no I'll be liking some
khaleesies door but what about
khaleesies straight-up whipped and
Dragons as police is all like this
straight roasting goats oh my god that's
when they start killing characters left
and right dog no guilt no kills
that was a four-for-one dog one up to go
straight for for one don't want to put
about when they got wildlings girl
talking about
kill me no guilt
slowly by omission yo who would buy my
man Taiwan Lannisters Taiwan Lannisters
mr. stuff oh my man talking about I'm
taking his kills by his own son what to
dingos the dinkles
dinkles know the dingo dinkles is my jam
eat nobody kill to deck that singles is
my jam my jelly my peanut butter and my
peanuts
[Music]